you like your terrorism in under 140
characters well then anonymous might be
coming for you anonymous then now
well-known hacker group has released
over 9,000 Twitter account names that
allegedly support Isis the group is
hoping that by publicly releasing the
Twitter account names that Twitter
itself will take action and remove the
accounts in a post on medium anonymous
implores the public's who joined the
fight to stop Isis from spreading its
message online it reads in part the more
attention it gets the more likely it
becomes Twitter takes action to remove
these accounts and making a serious
impact on the ability of Isis to spread
propaganda and recruit new members
alright so you guys know I'm an addicted
Twitter er I tweet roughly four thousand
times per day I do tweet a lot about
Isis I'm not an Isis supporter in case
that in case you were wondering or not
I'm not not an Isis supporter but it was
anonymous I'm not an Isis supporter yeah
no one but the idea that Anonymous is
going after the ISIS people on Twitter
for a second I was like well I do tweet
about Isis does that mean that they're
coming after me neither one of you have
that fear no although I don't I treat
more about my cat yeah Anonymous is
going after people who tweet too much
about their time the cat the cat people
are worse than the ISIS people they're
gonna go Isis and then they're gonna
come after us yeah I don't tweet that
much about I do tweet a lot I don't
tweet a lot about Isis yeah I think this
is good this is a good use of their
skillset yeah
teamed up with a couple of other hacker
groups so this seems like a positive use
of social media oh yeah so we've talked
a lot about the ISIS situation before in
social media and should we be playing
these videos should we show the pictures
all that stuff I not amiss is doing
something good here right well David's I
don't think you have to worry about them
thinking you do support ice a Jew
supporting Isis probably not will be
like us wearing the cats for making pro
dog tweets yeah okay so I think you're
safe there I don't think the problem I
think anonymous should I think they're
wasting time my twitter is the big
problem and I think that's just in our
world it seems big like everyone oh he
says well they're helping the propaganda
but you think that's not really I would
argue though that that I know the
terrorist groups are very popular on
social media and they use websites and
the web forum to spread their message
very effectively so it may not be
twitter alone but it's certainly part of
the mechanism that they use to spread
their propaganda when when I saw at CNN
we had a translator who worked very
diligently to help us decipher what was
going on in a lot of these chat rooms
and some online forums where a lot of
these messages were being sent so it may
actually be happening right under our
noses and under 140 characters right but
in in a very effective means especially
if you're trying to recruit young people
right so maybe two things can be true at
once that it's a good recruiting tool
but on the other hand in the media world
we're over blowing the I don't so so
Twitter is now the moral Police Twitter
can tell but who's on what side in a war
so Isis is also Isis is all bad but the
people fighting Isis is good sometimes
if they're on our side what's like WP
order sometimes it's the anti-isis pro
Saudi Arabia but anti Iran I mean we
don't know who the [ __ ] these people are
and I think it's ridiculous that Twitter
takes it upon themselves to decipher who
is good and who was bad in the Middle
East we don't know who's good at but the
whole reason why we have Isis is because
we didn't understand the sunni-shia
connection in the first place when we
went into Iraq right and now we've
unleashed this thousand-year-old war and
that's what this is about so can can use
Twitter if you're in the KKK can you use
Twitter if you're like Alec Baldwin and
you say negative things about gay people
when they put a camera in your face let
me use Twitter if you're in a neo-nazi
organization can you use Twitter if
you're considered by the Southern
Poverty Law Institute a racist
organization like the focus on the
family so who can use Twitter and who
can it's a very squiggly line of
morality right so they be Twitter should
stay the [ __ ] out of it and just provide
a platform of people in tweets [ __ ] in
144 characters right so just to be clear
we're talking about two separate things
here so one is whether Twitter will
allow people to post this stuff and the
other is whether anonymous is going to
go after these accounts I'm for freedom
of speech in all cases so I would say
let the accounts be there even though
they're up to no good and I would say
Twitter or any of these social media
sites shouldn't be policing what people
could put up we agree
we're agreeing all that all be the
dissent yeah you want to clean us up
getting put it yeah anything else - I
mean I just think that you have a
responsibility if you're going to run
some sort of social media site yeah
regulation isn't it really impossible to
police it like Anonymous is gonna do
whatever they're gonna do before for
Twitter to constantly be hunting these
people down is it yeah I mean it's not
going to be ideal it's not going you're
not gonna get everybody and you're not
gonna necessarily go after everybody but
I think that having a rule in place that
you can't tweet out heading videos or
that you're not using their social media
platform for bullying right I mean I
think that those are good rules to have
what do you think about the argument
that people should see these things
because when we've done it when we've
talked about it before I'm 50/50 on it
like on one hand I don't want to help
the propaganda on the other hand they're
doing horrible [ __ ] I mean I watched the
video of the Jordanian pilot burning it
was the most awful thing I'd literally
think you are zine in my life and I
don't know and on one hand I think
people should see it to see how horrible
it is and know what we're dealing with
and then on the other hand I don't want
to aid in the propaganda right I mean I
think you can go out and search for it
online if that's something you want to
see I know that I don't have the stomach
for it I can I can certainly hear about
it and no it's terrible and that's
enough for me just for me to want to get
angry and do something or to know where
I stand on a particular issue and if the
Internet is open and available and you
can go look for it if you actually need
to see it yeah but I don't know that we
necessarily need to have mechanisms in
place to promote it and that seems to be
what a lot of these platforms have been
for organizations like I all right now
you knew Benetton you watched those
videos
yeah beheadings in the burning yeah and
but you people don't know this about you
and I might be outing you here but you
watched four seasons of according to Jim
so it's like you got a steal you've got
a ton or toughness that I don't know I'm
used to torturing myself and really from
according to Jim the only thing that
could be worse was watching a human burn
so was it curiosity yeah but you know I
just felt I just felt I should know
about it in light of everything that I
do and talk matter that I should know
but knowing it happened or seeing the
pictures right before that wasn't an
athlete you wanted I just felt like I
should see it I don't know why maybe it
was just awful morbid curiosity
video while more horrible than according
to Jim still funnier yeah all right what
do you think should Anonymous be taking
down these twitter accounts should
Twitter be taking down these Twitter
accounts let us know in the comments
right